anemic start so they're cheating here
comes lebron looking for his first
good pass underneath count it foul and
one assist to lebron
another bucket to dwight out in the air
he changed his mind a bit and said here
i see you
looked off the defenders and gets a
three-point opportunity for dwight
howard
rozier checks back in howard five
minutes six point
big body underneath when he needs to be
grayson allen
pounded by dwight howard the steal it's
a four on one
love david
[Applause]
tapia little dwight howard lebron
five five
nba block shots already this year lebron
all the way lebron can't score another
cleanup by howard on the offensive glass
just flush lebron asking the official
why he's not at the line
there's a civ wasn't in balance and got
blown by
hey blocked by toy he's underneath
lakers lead the league in block shot
extremely confident on the offensive end
howard all gorgeous speed from dwight
howard cut going back door
he's got some real skills tell the truth
though mike he didn't lose some weight
he lost 50 pounds yeah give him credit
he's worked his tail off his way how
with the finish in the paint
glad to bring it to you we'll be on the
air again on sunday night currently it's
a
a 10-0 run bounce to dry he had it then
he recovered
and with two hands throws it down dave
murray has the rebound
out of the university of washington he
sat out there last game little load
management
on his part rondelle bounce daniels all
the way
put it up and in that obviously set up
because that happened too quick
ronda wanderer dwight to finish it
rondo to howard for the slam
rondo really in the middle of all of
that reed reed throw it up
let dwight throw it down lakers by eight
rondo now to lebron he's got a path to
the basket but a great
little love pass to dwight as all the
attention turned to lbj
other players look at that play where
lebron throws it up dwight throws it
down that's
recognition and knowing who's available
when the double team
kd comes lbj just out of the reach of
dwight
bounced from green one by howard yeah
i'll tell you dwight has been awesome
he's poised at the scorers about five
minutes so is jeff green
lob under
[Applause]
that he holds still with the memphis
franchise
dwight's going to take a big jumper
that's beautiful that's perfect
dwight howard yeah of course i could do
that
[Applause]
to north carolina dwight's going to
shoot a three it's on its way
and down it goes dwight howard that's
his 7-3 in his career
moment i mean it was nothing but net too
boy it wasn't like one of those bricks
that were
better thrown up there did you get this
thing
possibly in the keeley just want to put
it that way here is uh
the blazers with the basketball dave
moore again the lakers take it away
it's three on two caruso scores that's
what the analytics will tell you
jones on top with three to shoot he's
going to attack the ram
brockton is their leading scorer also
six the entire league
in assists kcp that's a good feed
and the two-hand don't fight dwight for
jcp that he
really lost control of the ball alex the
hook pass good hands by lebron
look at this feed to howard another
great
showtime feed from james to dwight
you're still holding on to that one
point advantage
rondo lob again this time howard that's
a good play by dwight
grabbed it and shot it with the left
hand that arm another look at rondo
findings
that play you just talked about catching
it while in the air and shooting it with
the left and then sabonis
dunk number 40 on the season for mason
for the miles plays in atlanta
underneath it's twice
as overpowering probably
[Applause]
doing a potential three-point players
dwight howard having some words with
harold
and michael green they're going up
against the 19th rated defense in the
nba in phoenix lebron skipping into the
lane
gives it off to dwight dwight with the
left hand he scores it
and counter he'll go to the line let me
take you inside what the team bus
or the media bus michael and uh stu
talking football
all the time michael loves chase young's
game
lakers working underneath with dwight
howard largest lead of the game
rondo orchestrating on top holding onto
it
being very patient underneath to dwight
quick turn and score
off the window three games and also as
stu alluded to consistency back-to-back
10-point games and he's always been a
rim protector and that's a good feed
good feed on the bounce to bradley who
scores again former bruin of ucla
born in santa monica and his father is a
former laker
caldwell pope under the twice slam it
home
at kcp setting up dwight howard for the
easy flush
but the lakers still trail on the
scoreboard 20
to 15. it's called build your stat
time now dwight
three got it
[Applause]
there's anthony another touch but he
can't control it again avery bradley
digging deep to get it ball moving out
to caruso
alex goes down the middle good feed slam
dunk by dwight we look at crucial also
finding dwight on the dribble
penetration and dwight with the easy
flush
there's anthony davis for three howard
and he scores plus the foul it's on
jared allen dwight howard's body is just
chiseled but look at that shoulder work
right there not an offensive file but
gary jr misses that james coming the
other way james throws it in
and howard big
lebron james put him in position to
catch and finish dwight howard
has an impact on this game in this first
half three guys he's trying to go up
through
[Music]
josie farrell dwight comes out of
nowhere
this one is yogi thinks he's got a
freebie here
all of a sudden dwight hits it twice and
the second time knocks it out of bounds
dwight who will be uh you know i think
calipari
and mike strzewski would both say
they've had the chance to coach the best
of the one-and-dones for the most part
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
once again lakers get out of the hurry
as caldwell
pope was able to drive and hit
dion waiters
dwight howard after setting the screen
on a roll to the basket there for the
pacers
howard one on one with turner howard
drop step and a little old-school dwight
howard powering his way to the rim
passes three rebound by
howard who's now out there with davis
and that's a foul
counted well that's so key for so many
players in this league
you gotta you gotta allow them to mature
it's a process developing
and the game slowing down for you
short-handed and all
putting up a fight here in this first
half we're all tied at 40.
blazers would love nothing more than to
extend this series
howard is fouled on his way and pretty
touch at the end
then you can fake it so you see simon's
thought that he was going to dribble
hand off
he faked it white side exp and the
blazers have to put nurkic
back on the floor maybe a little earlier
than terry stotz had hoped
lakers by two bullet pass inside howard
with the two-handed jam
pressure stays on the lakers
shot clock to two got to get one up
quick howard hammers it home
great set setup by kentavious caldwell
pope a.d could have just taken a bad
shot and
same with carl can't overreact you give
props to greatness
he scored the last six now they double
hard now top
and get the steal green on the break and
danny green
throws it down shot clock at four james
and he'll settle for the two and can't
get the follow but
that is howard with a follow in the foul
he's got 10 rebounds already very rarely
do you see red sorry
a guy tip dunk and get the foul shot
didn't go
all deflected caldwell pope dives on the
floor and saves it
james drives pass inside howard again
and the foul
transition opportunity get james ahead
of steam
and then the beautiful drop off to
dwight howard
he did not shoot the ball in game one
already three buckets